brothers scott and tyler heinemann
exchanged lineup cards with the umpires
and they did it for their mom and dad
and what a great moment that is that's a
christmas card right there that is a
christmas card indeed on the hill
tonight for the giants will be the
left-hander drew smiley 31 years of age
he's an eight-year veteran at the big
league level 6-2 190 pounder out of
little rock arkansas andrews bouncing
around at second to pitch
got him and he got the strikeout he was
looking for a little cut fastball the
right-handed power hitter todd frazier
nothing nothing two down runners at
first and third and the runner goes they
got it picked off belt checks the runner
and now solano is gonna go to third and
they now got andrews in a rundown
heinemann is going to go back and he's
going to
tag him out is solano and the umpires
down
watch heineman he's watching the play he
doesn't see jim wolfe
and he just smokes jim wolf that could
have been serious well i i think they
called him safe
i mean he took a shot and there's the
safe call right there 1-1
and this one out toward right field base
hit will get elvis home gallow heads to
the plate and that stolen base pays off
and a great start again in the first
inning for the rangers
got him and that's going to end the
inning on the hill tonight four the
texas rangers will be the big
right-hander jordan lyles six five 230
pounder he's 29 years of age and he's in
his ninth year at the big league level
so two men on two men out and here is
evan longoria
hammered out into right center field is
anybody there
no
two runs are going to score longoria
with one swing of the bat has tied this
game up one two
and a tapper
first base side lyles will take care of
it and that retires sandoval and the
giants here in the bottom of the first
inning so here's scott heinemann's gonna
hit while his brother behind the plate's
gonna try to get him out swinging gonna
miss on a pitch in the dirt brother tags
brother
got him filetha knew it felefin knew it
before barrett called it
got him
heinemann's going to block it and throw
him out five spike outs for smiley but
he's also thrown 50 pitches already tie
game 2-2 giants though have a great
chance as donovan salado comes up
driving a base hit that's going to score
a pair
dickerson rounds the bag at third in the
giants lead 4-2
strike three quality just did
get the corner and takes care of belt
and that's a huge out for lives 1-2
curveball swung on bounce to first
frazier's got it to second for one elvis
back to first
just in time a double play as frazier
got back to the bag to receive the throw
and lyles gets a big double play ball to
escape further trouble but the giants
scored two so smiley at a one two three
inning in the third three ground outs
swinging and a miss he got him
strikeout number six for drew smiley
just set them down in order struck him
out in the pitch in the dirt strike got
number seven two in this inning rev
snyder is going to lead things off
and he takes very high
and there's a strike pitch count wise
what do we got for drew smiley 71. yeah
he's fine and i don't know what's going
on
longoria noticed something or
gabe kepler's coming out and it looks
like smiley's got an issue
could be a cramp could be a blister on
his forefinger on his throwing hand well
you can't pitch without your
if you're having any numbness or
anything on your forefinger you're done
now i don't think he's very happy but if
you can't grip the ball you have nothing
to say about it seven strikeouts and
four innings
got him on the inside corner and that's
going to end the inning solano with the
two rbi signal in the third he also
lined out the third
he swings first pitch pops it up foul
ground
right field side gallow crossing the
line slides makes the catch just shy of
the warning track
in front of the sidewall a nice job by
joey gallo and solano's retired on one
pitch
[Applause]
he smashes this one out towards center
field ranging back on it though and
right there to make the catch heinemans
done a nice job in center field and the
bases are loaded and let's see what gabe
kepler does he's going to bring out
darren ruff one of those 0-2
got him swinging
two away that's a huge out for joe
palumbo and the rangers runners go and
they walked him and the giants pick up a
run on four walks one two
and this ball on the ground
but connor falefa is there
so here comes solano base is still
loaded
and a base hit to right field it's going
to knock in one and solano comes through
again at 6-2 and belt tanks low and
inside another walk a curveball he
curved him on three and two remembering
scott heineman to the plate one last
time one two to heinemann
and he shoots this one in the air out to
right field that one carrying well it's
gone
and heidemann goes yard it's 7-3 third
big league home run for scott heidemann
in an impressive one rangers down to
their final out got him and that's the
ball game and the giants win game two in
this series
[Applause]